living in California we saw what
happened with Gavin Newsom you saw what
happened with the lockdowns at one point
it was like you couldn't eat out it was
very similar it was a very close
parallel to what was happening in New
York and then the mandates and the
lockdowns extended beyond the point
where it was I mean the evidence was
there that this stuff just wasn't
working and yet they persisted was that
some of the impetus for you to cover
covid the way you did the fact that you
were in the belly of the Beast right
there living amongst it and seeing the
crazy that was going on
uh no I actually was covering covid from
the very beginning when the when
everyone in the whole country was in
lockdown so when everyone in the country
was going along with it even red States
so at the very very beginning I just
knew that wasn't going to work I mean it
was just obvious to me from seeing
because you know the United States got
the virus later than what had been going
on in Europe and in Parts you know Asia
of course like Israel right all of these
areas were getting the virus before we
were and it the data was already rolling
out by the time it hit us it was already
clear what was going to work and what
wasn't going to work and it was just
also I think obvious to me common sense
that locking down and hiding away from a
virus wasn't going to work when you open
your door the virus is going to be there
so yeah you might be able to delay it
for a bit of time but you're ultimately
eventually going to have to face the
Beast you can't lock down in your Panic
Room forever so
um I you know I was covering it actually
from the very beginning I was one of the
I think now looking back I think it's
pretty safe to say was probably one of
the only people in the beginning that
was very much against the lockdowns
amongst all of my all of the other
creators that I know or journalists that
I know that were covering it so you
weren't even on board with that initial
like three weeks that's fantastic and I
I admit to the audience that I I was I
was one of those people that got scared
I really did in the beginning I had this
four and a half month old and I saw
everything through a different lens uh
it's almost like I completely lost my
common sense I completely lost
everything I knew about health and
wellness and all I could see was this
little person and they were scaring me I
wasn't worried for me and I wasn't
worried for my husband I was worried for
this little baby and most the people
that were scaring me were traditional
medicine doctors who didn't know and
just felt like scaring you well let's
scare her and keep her you know as
worried as possible just in case that
was the philosophy they followed and of
course in New York you saw footage of
people in body bags and I mean they
really you didn't know the depth of what
had happened in terms of the wrong
things that were done in hospitals with
respect to treatment you didn't know
about you know what was happening in
nursing homes in New York and why that
was so you know so many people were
dying you didn't have any information
really you just all you had was the fear
so I think there were people that either
bought into it or didn't I I think
that's fantastic that you didn't I'm
deeply embarrassed to this day that I
wiped my packages down and did all of
that nonsense initially but I think it
was a moment of of real growth and
learning for me in terms of what what
can happen to someone when they give in
to fear at that point um and how long it
can go on I mean there's still people
that are in that place unfortunately
it's very very powerful luckily I think
rare now I think it's much more rare
that people are in that mindset there's
certainly still people but even flying
out here you know I didn't see I mean
there were very few people even at LAX
wearing a mask I mean it is just not a
few months ago when I was flying around
maybe it was like 30 percent you know
then it kind of dwindled and now it's I
mean it was extremely rare to see a
person wearing a mask most people are
maskless at this point but fear is
extremely powerful and I don't discount
that there's something very scary about
a virus
um and but you know for me my stance on
it it wasn't even just about covid and
the actual science of covid I felt a
lockdown and imposing that on a
population of people was wrong even if
it was the plague yeah for me it's it's
a personal choice I agree to get that
information and I think if it were the
plague most of us would stay inside
including myself I would make the choice
I'd be like I'm not going anywhere and I
am wiping down all my packages and I'm
doing all of this but that's my choice
and that to me was I think the biggest
was you know there's no way to outrun a
virus I don't even know if we can outrun
a plague for example it has to kind of
you know I I mean we would like to think
we could maybe do something and I think
that's we should always I think try to
some degree but when you rip Liberty
away from people I have a big problem
with that yeah yeah I they lost me on
the lockdowns after the three weeks
because I realized that could just
continue and continue at least we
started most of them were saying two
weeks to stop the spread so you're like
I'll give you three I'll give you three
and then I was really done and New York
was crazy I mean everyone really was
just panicked at the time um and I
always say I think if I didn't have a
child at that time I would have been a
very different person because probably
set in I was just I was still like
nursing him and I was like what happens
if I get sick and no one could answer
any questions it was just crazy I was
not in my right head I always say that
you have to like own up but wait were so
were you for lockdowns for others or
just for yourself I actually wasn't I
wasn't for forcing businesses to have to
lock down ever I was for like okay let's
just stay home for a little while let's
just see what happens here let's give it
a second it wasn't about government it
stepping in and forcing people it was
about let's just all make that decision
for ourselves and see what we can do to
figure out it was more like buying time
like what is this thing what is it doing
I did work from home for a really long
time that that was that was a
complicated thing because my mom then
had back trouble and it was in the midst
of covet and you couldn't go into a
hospital with anyone I was the only one
who got covered recovered was fine so I
was it was just a lot of factors and
craziness we also left the city at some
point but I I always
um talk to people about the fear because
I'm I'm somebody who is wired to
distrust these institutions big
government all of it and even I was like
afraid I was afraid um and I shouldn't
have been I look back now and I say I
shouldn't have been but it's an
important lesson for I think people who
are wired to trust those institutions
imagine then they already trust them you
layer in a level of fear and now forget
it I mean they're the people that are
still I still see people in Whole Foods
with masks on you know voluntarily and
I'm like oh wow if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]